[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous je suis ravi d'être là
je suis quelqu'un qui me pose beaucoup
de questions donc je vais commencer on
dispose pas vous poser des questions
lever la main si vous trouvez on vit
dans un monde très beau
tout ce monde ne pense pas confondre
le ville a levé la main qui vous pensez
malgré tout que vous avez des choses à
apporter à faire pour rendre ce monde
meilleur
le vélane a enfin si vous ou quelqu'un
que vous connaissez a déjà souffert de
la faim
aujourd'hui je suis pas venu vous parler
de problèmes dans le monde de la fin du
pauvre des guerres on en a assez entendu
aujourd'hui j'ai envie de vous raconter
une histoire
c'est l'histoire d'une naissance c'est
l'histoire d'une petite voix c'est
l'histoire d'une vision et c'est
l'histoire de rencontres au ch'ti est ce
que vous êtes prêt pour mon histoire
tout commence en 2011 avec la naissance
de mon premier fils qu'à elle
moment très émouvant avec beaucoup de
difficultés avec beaucoup de douleur
mais je reste toujours très bien coiffé
très bien ma quille
et quand quelques jours après je
reprends mes esprits et que je vois un
peu la bénédiction que je viens de
recevoir je vois que le bébé est en vie
et que moi aussi je vais très bien je
suis prise vraiment jeune d'un sentiment
immense reconnaissance et je le dis à ce
moment là
merci seigneur et je lui pose une
question une question qui va changer ma
vie à jamais je lui demande comment est
ce que je peux te remercier et ce que
j'entends n'est pas quelque chose de
classique j'entends pas fait une france
ou bien pardonne à telle personne ou
encore fait tel cadeau - chapelet non
non non ce que j'entends fait battre mon
coeur a mis à l'heure j'entends fait des
restos du coeur pour les enfants pour
information les restos du coeur saint
système d'entr'aide qui existent en
france où les personnes démunies peuvent
avoir un repas chauds par jour les
restos du coeur c'est des milliers de
camions dans toutes les villes de france
et ses 130 millions de repas par an
autant vous dire que quand j'ai entendu
ça j'ai un peu regretter d'avoir posé la
question mais la réponse était déjà
debout
et puis tout compte fait jouer j'ai
réfléchi un tout petit peu je me suis
dit
on vit dans un monde où au 21e siècle on
est capable quand même aujourd'hui
d'avoir tous des smartphones je vois
monsieur qu'il utilise tout le monde la
déception en ce moment je vois que côté
scientifique on fait de telles d'avancé
qu'on est capable de transplanter des
visages madame qui est ici qu est très
jolie si vous voulez ressembler à
beyoncé aujourd'hui vous pouvez mais
restez comme vous êtes
très joli à leur vraiment de toutes ces
avancées technologiques et après les
révolutions industrielles
toutes ces avancées scientifiques
il ya une chose qu'on n'arrive pas
encore à gérer c'est la faim dans le
monde et là je me dis quand même quand
quelque chose vous dérange je pense
qu'il faut se poser les bonnes questions
il faut essayer de comprendre il faut
essayer d'agir
alors l'action je parle d' agir mais
j'aime quand même trois ans 3 à me
décider 3 avec cette idée qui revenait
de façon insistante je me suis dit mais
par où commencer je me posais dix mille
questions et plus je me posais et plus
je resté bloqué j'estimais que j'étais
trop occupé j'étais je pouvais juste pas
m'attaquer à un projet aussi fou
et là j'ai eu un conseil un coup de
pouce moi j'appelle de l'univers un peu
plus de dieu un conseil celui de passer
à l'action 5 on sait qui me venait de
mon nez fille qui m'a bien matane qui
tiennent comme ans commence quelque part
et tu verras commence et quand il disait
commence moi j'entendais ça donc j'étais
vraiment très apeuré et j'étais vraiment
pas près de mons à l'action j'ai quand
même décidé de me lancer j'ai décidé de
commencer par 18 repas dijon pas que
j'allais offrir à des orphelins et quand
je suis arrivé à 7 à ce centre d'accueil
d'orphelins et que j'ai rencontré ces
enfants là j'ai dit quelque chose dans
leur vie à quelque chose qui m'a captivé
comme des étoiles dans les yeux et je me
souviens que j'ai appris mon père et je
lui ai raconté un peu la sensation
j'avais eue et m'a dit match des étoiles
à ces dieux qui te parle effectivement
je crois que c'est dieu qui ne parlait
parce que je n'ai pas pu arrêter de
distribuer des repas au fur et à mesure
des mois c'était 18 rolf 50 cents repas
mais je n'arrivais pas à m'arrêter et
j'allais toujours et le besoin était
prison et donc les quantités société
plus volumineuse et gien second couteau
de l'univers j'ai des rencontres de très
très belles rencontres des rencontres de
personnes loyales de personnes vraiment
motivés qui ont embrasé la vision tout
de suite et qui était tellement motivé
j'avoue qu'elle va chaleur temps à
m'appeler et moi je décrochais plus mon
téléphone se sentent fatigués elle était
vraiment trop en tout ça c'est trop
énergique est vraiment ces personnes
soient dans la salle et je m'excuse
n'aura pas décroché vos appels sera plus
heureux en juillet et avec ces personnes
là on se dit tous ensemble il faut qu'on
passe à l'action mais de façon plus
régulière et plus fréquentes pour avoir
plus d'impact nombre pas çà et là c'est
bien mais c'est vraiment insuffisant et
on a réfléchi on a nous ensemble nos
compétences moi je suis chef
d'entreprise chez maman auditop ancien
résident financiers je suis épouse et
j'ai mis toutes mes compétences
intellectuelles mes compétences de
négociatrice mais compte mes compétences
physiques aussi au service de la pause
et ces personnes là on en fait autant a
pris beaucoup de temps et nourricier de
penser un projet un projet qu'on a
appelé un défi parce que c'était
opération dix mille repas on s'est dit
de quelques repas qu'on fait ça et là on
envie de faire quelque chose qui a plus
d'impact à les dix mille repas donc
mille repas par mois
mauvais quartiers précaires de quoi
d'ivoire pas que d'abidjan alors on a
compris deux choses
deux choses la première c'est que si
c'est un business on aurait des
multimilliardaires parce que l'offre est
très peu et la demande est énorme il n'y
a pas de gens qui font ça dans le pays
malheureusement et la deuxième chose
après avoir sillonné les quartiers après
avoir sillonné les villages on a parlé
au chef on a parlé aux parents aux
enfants n'a pas nos enfants en conflit
avec la loi
après tous on a compris que le mal était
profond
mais on s'est dit on va quand même agir
on m'a pas se laisser un pas par
l'ampleur de la tâche on m'a quand même
faire quelque chose on a appelé chaque
personne à ramener des gens on a appelé
des professionnels
de la petite enfance de la nutrition on
appelait aussi à responsabiliser et on a
décidé de passer encore à une étape
supérieure au lieu de faire quelques
repas par an on a décidé de le faire des
repas par mois et maintenant on avait
décidé de faire des repas par jour on a
donc créé une entreprise sociale qui
s'appelle petit mas afrique et ses repas
par jour sont dans ce projet le ti des
jolies police c'est un petit déjeuner
offert tous les jours dans une école et
pourquoi on a fait ça parce que notre
travail de terrain nous a montré que le
besoin était profond et le besoin
n'était pas juste de façon sporadique
ils étaient régulés il fallait pour
avoir un impact ya quelque chose de très
soutenu et deuxièmement le besoin se
fait sentir chez les tout petits c'est à
dire chez notre futur si le futur de
cette société chez la côte d'ivoire de
dans dix ans et donc il fallait faire
quelque chose à la base on a
créé donc ce pti déjeuner qui est
inquiet équilibré qui est goûteux aussi
et qu'on distribue tous les jours aux
élèves dans la classe à leur table pour
éviter ceux qui seront tentés de se
répéter de faire l'école buissonnière
est juste de venir prendre le petit
déjeuner et sortir donc
on a mis en place dès des indicateurs de
performance on a collecté des
informations parce qu'on n'avait pas
juste envie de faire une action sociale
vous voulez faire une action sociale qui
a de l'impact
est vraiment dieu merci les premiers
résultats tombent
c'est le boom le bout au niveau du taux
de présence qui passe de 75 8% à 92 8 1%
et une des écoles dans laquelle on fait
le petit déjeuner colis est passé par un
classement national qui s'appelle le
classieux paix le cas semant des écoles
primaires est passé de la 23e à la
troisième place
complètement tient là quelque chose qui
frappe qui fonctionne quelque chose qui
marche est quelque chose qui nécessite
des tricks et d'être déployé à l'échelle
nationale voire même régionales parce
que le problème on l'a ressenti en côte
d'ivoire n'est pas qu'un problème local
malheureusement on a décidé tout ce qui
ne progresse pas et voit l'échec n'est
ce pas donc on a décidé de pourrait si
on a répliqué ce modèle dans une
deuxième école même tendance même
résultat les résultats se sont nettement
améliorées les enfants sont motivés les
profs sont motivés et les paroles qui
font leur travail derrière et cela on
s'est dit ok on veut aussi soutenir
l'éducation donc on a lancé un projet
qui s'appelle je parraine un enfant qui
consiste à offrir des bourses scolaires
à des orphelins à travers le pays et
bien évidemment ce programme là aussi
motive les élèves parce que derrière les
parents demandent des notes des enfants
et caetera et l'enfant siècle il ya une
âme généreuse qui a payé ses études et
l'enfant fait des efforts pour l'école
tout ceci pour vous dire que nous sommes
le thème aujourd'hui c'est nous venaient
nouvelle ère pour moi c'est pas juste
hilaire de la prise de conscience terme
de l'action l'action
intelligente l'action avec des choses
qui fonctionnent c'est l'ère de la
responsabilité
c'est l'heure de la décision personne ne
va faire ce travail à notre place ici de
nous mêmes et je pense qu'on va tous se
motiver à agir à ne plus juste rester là
à réfléchir on a déjà assez réfléchi
maintenant passons à l'action
selon notre travail on estime que
nourrir les enfants intellectuellement
et physiquement sur leur lieu de travail
nous permettra de résoudre de nombreux
problèmes de société on fait bien
entendu allusion aux amphis aux enfants
en conflit avec la loi qui agresse qui
font beaucoup de dégâts parce qu'ils
sont peut-être pas sainement occupés ou
parce qu'ils n'ont pas leurs besoins
primaires conflit
alors pour moi c'est quoi agir agir
c'est premièrement analyser comprendre
ce s'attaquer à un problème à la fois et
rester focus est resté sur des choses
qui auront encore de l'un portant sur le
long terme j'ai pour gravir accepté de
commencer petit ne pas se laisser
submerger par l'envergure de l'ambition
et un autre jld et maman agir la 2g edge
un autre j'ai c'est être dans la
gratitude pour la vie pour ce qui est et
pour les petits pas accompli il pour
s'impliquer autant d'atouts s'impliquer
avec sérieux avec l'aigle arrêté et si
possible avec professionnalisme et air
pour rallier rallier des personnes
autour de soi qui vont nous aider à
porter qui vont nous aider trois qui
vont nous aider à nous relever qui vont
nous apporter un nouvel erp mois les
premières personnes que j'ai rallié à la
cause pour ses enfants sont mes enfants
mais c'est un garçon qui aujourd'hui
nous accompagne sur
7 dans ses actions de petites mains et
qui le font avec beaucoup d'entrain même
si j'avoue y en a quand même qui passe
longtemps essayé d'avoir des plans pour
s'accaparer des cadeaux de noël des
arbres de noël ils le font quand même
avec beaucoup d'amour et populaire et au
fun j'ai commencé par éducation j'ai
terminé par une question j'aimerais que
ce soit vous qui vous posiez cette
question
qu'est ce que je veux voir dans ce monde
et la deuxième question c'est comment
est ce que je peux faire ma part
posez vous cette question sincèrement et
surtout n'oubliez pas
passer à l'action commencer quelque part
je finis par cette citation qui dit que
rappelez vous que lorsque vous quittez
cette terre vous n'apportez rien de ce
que vous allez assure uniquement ce que
vous avez donné
merci je m'appelle chrétienne et ça fait
huit ans que je changer le monde merci
[Applaudissements]